Last year, when Tolisha Lee called 2-on-1, so that she and her son could get help with housing or shelter, the operator told her to go and do an assessment so that she could get into the coordinated entry system, or CES, as she calls it. Okay. So tomorrow, you can go at 1 p.m. at the Henry Robinson Multiservice Center to do an assessment for the CES program. Tullisha did that. She sat down with a social worker and answered some questions and was entered into the system, but she didn't end up getting any help with housing. I think I just feel like somebody they forgot about me. They forgot about me and my son. When Tullisha entered that system, she was essentially being put on a big long list with a bunch
去年，托莉莎·李（Tolisha Lee）拨打2-1-1寻求住房或庇护所的帮助时，接线员让她去进行评估，以便她能够进入所谓的协调准入系统（Coordinated Entry System，简称CES）。好的。那么明天下午一点，你可以去亨利·罗宾逊多服务中心（Henry Robinson Multiservice Center）为CES项目做评估。托莉莎照做了。她和社工坐在一起回答了一些问题，并被录入了系统，但她最终并没有得到任何关于住房的帮助。我觉得自己就像是被别人遗忘了。他们把我跟我儿子都忘了。当托莉莎进入该系统时，她实际上是被列入了一个长长的大名单，里面有一群
of other homeless people. But what she didn't realize and what I didn't know at the time was that this list, it wasn't just a first-come, first-serve queue. It was a list of all the homeless people in Alameda County ranked according to need. The people at the top were considered the most in need of housing and they were prioritized first for help. I don't think it's hyperbolic to say that people may actually live or die according
其他无家可归的人。但她没有意识到，当时我也不知道，这个名单不仅仅是一个先到先得的队列。它是阿拉米达县所有无家可归者的名单，并按需求进行了排序。排在最前面的人被认为最需要住房，他们被优先获得帮助。我认为说人们实际上可能根据他们在这个名单上的最终位置而生或死，一点也不夸张。无家可归是致命的。2000年代初洛杉矶的一项研究发现，无家可归者的平均死亡年龄是48岁，而且总体而言，其预期寿命缩短了大约36%。住房等于更多的寿命，而排在名单的前列是获得住房的途径。我想知道，作为一个苦于精神健康挣扎并带着孩子住在车里的单亲妈妈，为什么托莉莎在名单上的排名不够高而无法获得帮助。
to where they end up on this list. Homelessness is lethal. A study in Los Angeles in the early 2000s found that the average age of death for a homeless person was 48 years old, and that life expectancy is about 36% shorter overall. Housing equals more years of life, and being at the top of the list is a path to housing. I want to know why as a single mom struggling with her mental health and living in a car with her kid, Tullisha wasn't high enough on the list to get help.
她是离得很近还是相差很远？如果这是一个按需求排名的榜单，他们是如何确定谁的需求最大的？为了找到这些问题的答案，我将带你深入了解这个官僚机构。就像俄罗斯套娃一样，这件事是有层次的。但我保证，我们将解开蒂蕾莎最终在这个名单上的什么位置以及为什么它辜负了那么多人的谜团。这是根据需求第四章。如果我想知道蒂蕾莎在名单上的位置，我需要找到一个
Was she close or far? And if this is a ranking of needs, how are they determining who's need is the greatest? To find the answers to these questions, I'm going to take you deep inside of this bureaucracy. Like Russian nesting dolls, there's layers to this thing. But I promise we are going to solve the mystery of where Tilecia ended up on this list and why it fails so many people. This is according to Need, Chapter 4. If I wanted to know where Tleisha had been on the list, I'd need to find someone who
有权访问它、能够真正在电脑屏幕调出并查看它的人。但事实证明这很困难。是的，我找到了2019年9月我与她进行的第一次通话。在我的笔记里，是的，来电者一直和她的儿子睡在车里。这是埃尔莎·冈萨雷斯（Elsa Gonzalez）。她在211工作，实际上就是她告诉蒂蕾莎去加入协调准入系统的接线员。换句话说，就是加入名单。作为接线员，你能看到她最终会在那个名单的什么位置吗？
had access to it, who could actually pull it up on their computer screen and look at it. But that proved to be difficult. Yeah, so I found her first call that I had with her back September 2019. In my notes, yeah, Collar has been sleeping in her car with her son. This is Elsa Gonzalez. She works at 211 and she's actually the operator who told Tillyia she should go and get into the coordinated entry system. Or in other words, get on the list. And are you like, as an operator, are you able to see where she would have ended up on that list?
不。那个名单。我的意思是，今天我甚至对某人说，嘿，我不知道他们是如何对名单进行优先排序的。我不知道他们是如何从名单中挑选人员的。但他们把你弄上了名单。他们非常擅长让人上名单。然后突然之间你就不在名单上了，或者你一路掉回了名单的最底部。
No. The list. I mean, today I even told someone, hey, I don't know how they prioritize the list. I don't know how they're pulling people from the list. But they get you on the list. They're very good at getting people on lists. And then all of a sudden you're not on the list or you went all the way back down to the bottom of the list.
这一切都是个巨大的谜团。你知道，那个名单是……是的，所以你给我们讲述了关于法律和立法权的事情。我进行了很多关于名单及其背后官僚体制的对话。我还没有发现任何关于蒂蕾莎的具体情况。但我学到的一件事是，这个国家管理无家可归者服务的方式是，住房和城市发展部（简称HUD）每年向非营利组织发放巨额补助金，这些非营利组织将自己组织成各个社区。
It's all a huge mystery. You know, that list is... Yeah, so you're giving us about the power of law and legislation. I had so many conversations about the list and the bureaucracy behind it. And I hadn't found out anything specific about Tulecia yet. But one thing I learned is that the way homeless services are administered in this country is that the Department of Housing and Urban Development, A.K.Hud, gives big grants every year to nonprofits that have organized themselves into communities.
例如，阿拉米达县的所有非营利组织都是一个集团的一部分，他们共享一笔资金。HUD通常无法向这些当地社区提供他们申请的所有资金，因为HUD本身也没有从国会获得它要求的所有资金。由于资金匮乏，几年前，HUD告诉全美各地的
Like, for example, all the nonprofits in Alameda County are part of one group, and they share one pot of money. HUD isn't usually able to give these local communities all of the funding they apply for, because HUD itself also doesn't get all the funding it asks for from Congress. And because funding is scarce, a few years ago, HUD told local communities all over the
社区，他们必须实施系统——协调准入系统，以确保有限的资源流向最需要帮助的人。这意味着在美国各地，像阿拉米达县这样的社区必须制作一份他们特定区域内所有无家可归者的名单，按需求进行排序。然后弄清楚如何将可用资源提供给这些人，优先考虑名单顶部的人。最终，我发现阿拉米达县主导实施协调准入系统工作的组织叫做“人人有家”（Everyone Home）。所以“人人有家”的某个人可能会接触到这个名单。
US, they would have to implement systems, coordinated entry systems to make sure the limited resources went to the people most in need. What this meant was that all over the US, communities like Alameda County had to make a list of all the homeless people in their particular area ranked according to need. And then figure out how to get the available resources to those people, prioritizing the people at the top of the list. Eventually, I figured out that in Alameda County, the organization that led the effort to implement the coordinated entry system was called Everyone Home. So maybe someone at Everyone Home had access to the list.
听着，总得有人在看这东西并对排在最上面的人做出决定，对吧？嘿，你好吗？凯蒂。朱莉。很高兴见到你。那是朱莉，格拉德·贝特。
Like, someone has to be looking at this thing and making decisions about the people at the top of it, right? Hey, how are you? Katie. Julie. Nice to meet you. That's Julie, glad better.
她后来离开了这个组织，但她过去曾在“人人有家”工作，并协助建立协调准入系统。这部分就像是一个至关重要的部分，对我来说仍然有点神秘，即协调准入部分。是的。每个人都在不停地提到这个名单，对吧？是的，感觉有点像《绿野仙踪》。我猜我的第一个问题是，比如，你是那个巫师吗？
She's since left the organization, but she used to work for everyone home and she helped put the coordinated entry system in place. This part of it is like a crucial piece which remains kind of mysterious to me, the coordinated entry piece. Yeah. Everyone's always referring to the list, right? Yeah, it feels a little bit like the Wizard of Oz. I guess my first question is, like, are you the Wizard?
这里是奥兹国吗？我不是巫师。这里不是奥兹国。但我可以给你系统手册，上面解释了整个事情。真的吗？是的。我确实有一张奥兹国的地图。好吧，我们能一起看一下吗？
Is this Oz? I am not the Wizard. This is not Oz. But I can give you the system manual, which explains the whole thing. Really? Yeah. I do have a map of Oz. Okay, can we like look at it together?
可以。当HUD要求全国各地的社区实施这个按需求对人进行排序的系统时，对朱莉和她的同事来说，问题就变成了：好吧，谁最需要帮助？我们应该优先为这些非常非常紧缺的资源资助谁？在萨姆斯和巴里切斯在“住房优先”政策上取得非常成功的工作之后，专家和政策制定者开始认为
Yes. When HUD asked communities all over the country to implement this system that ranked people according to need, the question for Julie and her colleagues became, okay, who is the most in need of health? Who shall we prioritize for these very, very scarce resources? After SAMS and Barrices, very successful work with housing first, experts and policymakers started to think
应该优先获得资源的人，就是萨姆斯一直在共事的那类人。那些经常面对许多挑战的人，精神或身体疾病、残疾、瘾症。研究表明，如果没有人干预，这些人最有可能死在街头。更重要的是，他们也最可能是那些会使用高昂服务（如收容所、戒毒中心或急诊室）的人。
that the people who should be prioritized for resources were the kinds of people SAMS had been working with. People who are often dealing with a lot of challenges, mental or physical illnesses, disabilities, addiction. These were the people that research showed were the most likely to die on the street if no one intervened. And importantly, they were also the people most likely to use costly services like shelters or detox centers or ERs.
但人们担心这些人得不到服务，因为他们很难与人合作，或者很难为自己发声。因此，协调准入的出现也是在一个人们说“等等，真正需要这个的人却没有得到它”的时期。因此，当阿拉米达县的人们（如朱莉）开始回答那个问题——谁应该被优先考虑？——他们会想到那个群体，他们也会询问无家可归者本身。你知道，很多挣扎的人会说“但我那边的那个人，那个人比我更需要帮助”。最后，阿拉米达县想出了一种脆弱性评估，基本上就是一份问卷。这就是托莉莎和社工做过的那件事，她必须回答一些问题，比如：
But there was a fear that these folks weren't getting services, because they were hard to work with or had a hard time self-advocating. So, Coordinate Entry also came at a time where people said, wait, the people who really need this are not getting it. And so as the folks in Alameda County, like Julie, started to answer that question, who should be prioritized? They would have been thinking about that group, and they also asked homeless people themselves. You know, a lot of the folks that I'm struggling, but that person over there, that person needs help before I do. In the end, Alameda County came up with a vulnerability assessment, a questionnaire, basically. This was the thing Talisha had done with the social worker, where she had to answer questions like,
你家里有人患有抑郁症或精神分裂症吗？你有残疾吗？你有任何慢性健康状况吗？在过去的30天里，你有没有为了生存而做过感觉不安全的事情？阿拉米达县名单上的每一个无家可归者都接受了同样的评估，根据他们对每个问题的回答，他们会得到一个分数，正是这个分数决定了他们在名单上的位置。这就是你听说这个名单的由来。而且这个名单现在很长。目前大约有8000个家庭
does anyone in your household suffer from depression or schizophrenia? Do you have a disability? Do you have any chronic health conditions? In the past 30 days, have you had to do things that felt unsafe to survive? Every homeless person on Alameda County's list has been given this same assessment and depending on how they answer each question they get a score and it's that score that determines their place on the list. So that's where you hear about the list. And the list is long right now. There are currently around 8,000 households
在阿拉米达县的名单上。一个家庭可以是一个个人，也可以是带着孩子的母亲，等等。朱莉说，她认为在这8000个家庭中，只有大约20%的人会得到某种资源。这些资源都某种程度上保存在电子表格中。只有几百个这样的家庭，也就是名单最顶端的那些，会得到你在上一章中听到的那种住房，
on Alameda County's list. A household can be an individual or it can be a mother in her kids, for example. And Julie said she thinks of those 8,000 households, only about 20% will get some kind of resource. The resources are all kept sort of on spreadsheets. And only a few hundred of those households, the ones at the very top of the list, will get the kind of housing that you heard about in the last chapter,
现在被称为永久性支持性住房，你的房租在你的余生中得到补贴，并且你可以获得其他支持性服务。人们还可以得到其他不太密集的干预措施，比如短期的房租帮助或一次性的押金帮助。但如我们所知，蒂蕾莎没有得到这些东西中的任何一样。遗憾的是，朱莉并不是那个能准确告诉我原因的人。所以，当你在名单上被排序时，这会给你在名单上的排名。但随后你要进行匹配，所以这就是匹配。那些在外面的做这件事的人，顺便问一下，那些人是谁？他们遍布全县。
what's now called permanent supportive housing, where your rent is subsidized for the rest of your life plus you get access to other supportive services. There are other less intense interventions people can get, like short-term help with rent or one-time help with a deposit. But Tilecia, as we know, got none of these things. And sadly, Julie was not the person who could tell me exactly why. And so, when you're ordered on the list, that gives you a rank on this list. But then you're matching, so this is the mattress. These people out there who are doing this, by the, who are those people? They're all across the county.
这些匹配人员，他们是那些查看名单并将顶端的人与住房等资源进行匹配的人。我需要和其中一个人谈谈。哦，嗨。长话短说，我不得不发更多邮件，打更多电话，然后，最后，我找到了一个匹配员，一个有权访问名单的人。你好吗？很好。在家办公？
These mattress, they are the people that look at the list and match the people at the top with resources like housing. I needed to talk to one of them. Oh, hi. And long story short, I had to talk to one of them. Oh, hi. And long story short, I had to send a bunch more emails, make a bunch more calls, and then, finally, I found a matcher, a person with access to the list. How are you doing? Good well. Working from home?
是的。这是拉奎莎·利文斯顿（Laquisha Livingston），她是一名匹配员。我在做匹配工作，从我们的工作来看，这是非常公正的，因为计算机告诉我，它是基于一个评分系统，哪些家庭比其他家庭有更高的需求。拉奎莎为一家名为“建设未来”（Building Futures）的组织工作，她花了很多时间查看名单的一个子集，其中包含带孩子的家庭。当你整天都在看那个名单时，比如看着它，你就会对
Yes. This is Laquishaisha livingston and she is a match. I am doing the matching and it's very unbiased as far as our work because the computer tells me it's based on a scoring system which families are higher need than other families. Lakisha works for an organization called building futures and she spends a lot of time looking at a subsection of the list that includes households with kids. When you're looking at that list all day every day, like, look at it, you kind of become really familiar with
人们在哪里，他们的排名是什么变得非常熟悉，从某种意义上说，这简直令人着迷。拉奎莎不仅查看名单，她还能告诉我蒂蕾莎在她的脆弱性评估中得了多少分，这最终决定了她在名单上的高低位置。这就是我一直在找的人。我试图保持冷静，但我太兴奋了。是的，这也是我希望你们能与我分享的一部分，这样我就可以理解为什么像她这样的人不会搬进庇护所或住房。所以我不能具体告诉你她的分数。
where people are, what they rank, and it's just like mesmerizing in a sense. Not only does Laquisha look at the list, but she could tell me what Tileisha had scored on her vulnerability assessment, which is ultimately what determines how high or low she would have been on the list. This was the person I'd been looking for. I was trying to keep it cool, but I was so excited. Yeah, and is that that's part of what I was hoping you guys would share with me is so that I can understand kind of like why someone like her wouldn't have moved into shelter or housing. So I can't specifically give you her score.
我真的以为我当时的希望破灭了。但随后，也在通话中的拉奎莎的主管插话道：“没关系，我们得到了蒂蕾莎的许可来分享这些信息。”好的，让我看看。所以我现在在看实际的评估。蒂蕾莎开始快速浏览蒂蕾莎在评估中的回答。你知道，她无家可归过好几次。她指出她勾选了心理健康、慢性健康状况。所有这些加起来的总分是，所以她当时是120分。120分。这就是她的120分。120分。
I truly thought my hopes had been dashed in this moment. But then, Laquisha's supervisor who was also on the call jumped in and was like, it's cool we have permission from T'laisha to share this info. Okay, let me see here. So I'm licking at the actual assessment right now. Tulecia starts skimming through Tulecia's answers on the assessment. She has been homeless, you know, multiple times. She states that she checked mental health, chronic health conditions. All of this added up to a score of, so she was at a 120. 120. That was her a 120. 120.
这就是她在评估中的得分。你的分数越高，就被认为越脆弱，你在名单上的排名就越高。这高于平均范围，但还不够高。就像现在，如果我正在看名单来安置家庭，我甚至连120分都没到。真的吗？我仍然……是的，我还在大约150分左右。
That was her score on the assessment. The higher your score, the more vulnerable you're considered to be and the higher you are on the list. It's above the average range, but just not quite high enough. Like right now, if I'm looking at the list to place families, I'm not even near 120. Really? I'm still... Yes, I'm still at about 150.
拉奎莎说，有很多人的得分是150、160、190或更高。他们在脆弱性评估中勾选了比托莉莎更多的选项。因此，他们的名单排名比她高。残疾是一个大项。HIV阳性是另一个。另一个能在评估中为你赢得更多分数的因素是无家可归的时间长度。蒂蕾莎在车里只待了几个月。在此之前，她和朋友或家属挤在一起，根据这个系统，这甚至不算是无家可归。由于资源如此有限，而且有那么多人被认为比托莉莎更脆弱，以至于她始终没能落到那个仍然脆弱但还不够脆弱的120分档。有时这真的很令人沮丧，因为你想帮忙，而且你知道我们有必须遵守的规划
There are lots of people, Laquisha says, who score 150 or 160 or 190 or higher. They just ticked more boxes on the vulnerability assessment than Tullisha. And so they ended up higher on the list than her. Disability is the big one. HIV positive is another one. Another factor that gets you more points on the assessment is the length of time homeless. Tilecia had only been in the car for a few months. Before that, she was doubled up with friends or family members, which doesn't even count as homeless, according to this system. There were such limited resources, and so many people considered more vulnerable than Talicia that she just never made it down to the still vulnerable but not vulnerable enough. 120's. It's devastating sometimes because you want to help and you know we have programmatic
规则，所以这就是那种事情之一，你只能想，你知道，这是我的工作，我没有创造这个系统，但这就是系统运作的方式，你只能，你知道的，但这确实对你造成了影响。所以，好吧，托莉莎的脆弱性得分为120分，略高于平均水平。她没有勾选足够的选项来获得更高的分数。
rules that we have to follow so it's just one of those things that is, that you just kind of, you know, this is my job and I don't make the system, but this is the way the system is operating and you just, you know, but it does take a toll on you. So, okay, Tullisha had a slightly above average vulnerability score of 120. She hadn't checked enough boxes to get a higher score.
她没有勾选诸如“你是否曾因制造冰毒或纵火而被定罪”或“你对毒品或酒精有过度依赖吗”之类的事情。在现有的系统中，这些事情实际上会帮助你爬到名单的最顶端，因为它们被认为是很难靠自己找到住房的指标。如果没有人干涉，有这些问题的人更有可能继续无家可归。
She didn't check things like have you ever been convicted of methamphetamine production or arson or do you have an excessive dependency on drugs or alcohol? And in the system we have now, those things actually help you move to the top of the list because they're thought of as indicators that it's going to be hard for you to get into housing on your own. People with those kinds of issues are more likely to stay homeless if no one intervenes.
所以这在某种程度上讲得通，对吧？但一个在某种程度上奖励成瘾或犯罪记录等行为的系统，对某些人来说是有争议的。每个人对谁应该被优先考虑、谁不应该都有自己的看法。然后你会听到很多关于谁值得、谁不值得的讨论。再次听到朱莉·莱德贝特的声音，她帮助在阿拉米达县建立了这个系统。这在很大程度上表现为“那个吸毒者不配”。
So that makes some sense, right? But a system that in a way rewards things like addiction or criminal record, it's going to be controversial to some people. Everybody has their own opinion about who should be prioritized, who shouldn't. And then you hear a lot of conversation about who's deserving, who's not deserving. Again, Julie Ledbetter, who helped build this system in Alameda County. It's manifested a lot in terms of like that drug user doesn't deserve it.
为什么他们要被优先考虑？当你回想事情与萨姆斯和巴里切斯刚开始实行“住房优先”时有多大不同，这太疯狂了。在“住房优先”之前的情况是，只有那些干净且精神足够健全、能够驾驭系统的人才能获得住房。现在恰恰相反。现在，你有越多的这类障碍和脆弱性，你就越有可能获得帮助。
Why are they getting prioritized? It's wild when you think about how far things are from when Samsung bearers started housing first. The way it looked pre-housing first was that only people who are clean and mentally sound enough to navigate the system, God housing. Now is the opposite. Now the more of these kinds of barriers and vulnerabilities you have, the more likely you are to get help.
HUD以及因此而获得资助的所有地方社区决定专注于这个群体，出于道德和财务两方面的考虑。如果这个群体不搬进室内，他们确实更有可能死在街头。而且如果他们继续留在室外，他们也最可能让政府花钱。但是——请听我说完——无论出于何种原因，优先考虑这个群体在某些社区产生了意想不到的后果。它实际上可能最终偏袒白人。我和其他人的担忧之一是，由于存在如此多的结构性 racism（结构性种族主义），如果你是黑人，要变得无家可归要容易得多。这是玛戈·库塞尔（Margot Kushel）。
HUD and as a result, all of the local communities it funds have decided to focus on this group for reasons both moral and financial. This group really is more likely to die on the street if they don't come inside. And also they're the most likely to cost the government money if they stay outside. But and stay with me me here, prioritizing this group, whatever the reason. It's had an unintended consequence in some communities. It can actually end up favoring white people. One of my and other people's concerns have been that because there's so much structural racism, it is much easier to become homeless if you're black. This is Margot Coushell.
她是一名医生，也是加州大学旧金山分校无家可归问题研究员。所以我们看到的是，如果你只看无家可归的人口，黑人看起来更健康，因为在黑人中无家可归可能意味着你只是穷。总的来说，这是一个笼统的概括，但总的来说，无家可归的白人中，有更高比例的人拥有与他们的无家可归相关的这些残疾，当然不是所有人，但你更有可能有。
She's a doctor and a researcher on homelessness at the University of California, San Francisco. So what we see if you just look within the homeless population, the black folks look healthier because to be homeless in black means you could just be poor. And in general, this is a sweeping generalization, but in general, more a higher proportion of the white folks who are homeless have these disabilities that are related to their homelessness, not everyone, of course, but you're more likely.
我想在这里插话，因为我认为这很难理解，但很重要。所以，好吧，这样想：一个白人正站在跳水板上，而无家可归就是如果他们从边缘掉下去会发生的事情。但这是一个很长的跳水板，有足够的空间。每一个个人的困难都是向边缘推的一把。工伤，推一下；抑郁症的发作，推一下；成瘾，再推一下。当这个白人走到边缘并最终跌入无家可归时，他们可能已经累积了大量的
I want to jump in here because I think this is tricky to understand, but important. So okay, think about it like this. A white person is standing on a diving board, and homelessness is what happens if they fall over the edge. But it's a long diving board with plenty of space. Every personal difficulty is a push toward the edge. An injury on the job, a little push, the onset of depression, a push, an addiction, another push. By the time this white person gets to the edge and finally falls into homelessness, they may have accumulated a lot of
推力。你可以把这些看作是脆弱性。另一方面，有色人种，尤其是黑人，由于种族财富差距和系统性种族ism（种族主义）造成的其他差异，他们一开始的跳水板往往更短，这意味着轻轻一推就可能把一个黑人推过边缘。因此，相对健康的陷入无家可归的黑人会更多。当涉及到协调准入系统时，这一点很重要，因为如果人们积累了更多的脆弱性，如成瘾、精神疾病等，系统就会给他们更高的分数。因此，审视这一点的人发现，这在全国许多地方都是如此，白人更有可能获得资源，仅仅是因为他们的得分更高，因为这些评分系统都是基于个人脆弱性的。
pushes. You can think of these as vulnerabilities. On the other hand, people of color, and especially black people, because of the racial wealth gap and other disparities caused by systemic racism, they just often have a shorter diving board to begin with, which means one little push might send a black person over the edge. So there are just more relatively healthy black people who fall into homelessness. And this matter is when it comes to the coordinated entry system because the system gives people a higher score if they've accumulated more vulnerabilities like addiction, mental illness, etc. And so what people who have interrogated this have found, and this is true in many places across the country, is that the white folks are more likely to get resources just because they score higher because these scoring systems are all based on individual vulnerability.
应该说，阿拉米达县实际上已经通过在评估中添加不同类型的问题来努力解决这个问题。而且白人目前获得资源的比例并不比有色人种高。但评估中的这些问题在美国其他地方仍然是个问题。我觉得我们可以从中看出，很难找到一个适合所有人的脆弱性框架。比如，这个如此专注于精神疾病和
Alameda County, I should say, has actually worked to address this issue by adding different kinds of questions to their assessment. And white people are not currently getting resources at a higher rate than people of color. But these issues with the assessment are still a problem in other places across the US. And I feel like what we can see from this is that it's hard to find a framework for vulnerability that fits everyone. Like, where does this framework, which focuses so much on things like mental illness and
成瘾等问题的框架，把蒂蕾莎的儿子乔丹置于何地？他是一个11岁的孩子，没有那些特定问题，但在许多不同的方面都很脆弱。所以，好吧，评估过程并不完美，但最大的问题，最大的问题不是弄清楚谁最脆弱有多棘手。而是阿拉米达县有8000人在名单上，其中绝大多数人什么也得不到。更不用说所有那些
addiction, where does it leave Tilecia's son Jordan, an 11 year old kid who doesn't have those particular issues, but is vulnerable in so many different ways? So okay, the assessment process isn't perfect, but the biggest problem, the biggest problem isn't that figuring out who the most vulnerable people are is tricky. It's that in Alameda County, there are 8,000 people on the list and the vast majority of them will get nothing. Not to mention all of the people
甚至根本没有进入名单的人了，因为他们不被认为是字面意义上的无家可归。那些没有从系统中得到任何帮助，甚至没有进入系统的人，并没有就此消失。他们中的一些人会设法回到住房中，但许多人不会。最终，一些人会陷入更脆弱
who never even make it onto the list to begin with, because they aren't considered literally homeless. And those people who don't get any help from the system or who don't even get to enter the system, they don't just disappear. Some of them will find their way back into housing, but many of them won't. And eventually, some folks will end up in more vulnerable
且通常更显眼的无家可归形式。睡在朋友沙发上的人最终可能会睡在车里，但接着车被拖走了，他们最终睡在路边的帐篷里。在这个过程中，他们积聚了创伤。他们受伤、遭到袭击，或者由于压力引发精神健康危机。最终，会有越来越多的人能够在脆弱性评估中勾选许多选项。
and often more visible forms of homelessness. People who start out on a friend's couch may end up in a car, but then the car gets towed and they end up in a tent by the side of the road. Along the way, they accumulate trauma. They get injured or assaulted or have mental health crises brought on by stress. Eventually, there are more and more people who can check a lot of those boxes on the vulnerability assessment.
甚至连所有人都不够资源。这就是阿拉米达县目前正在发生的事情。这个系统完全不堪重负。系统要做好、要保持善意、要高效、要清晰的压力，感觉就像是一种负担。我的意思是，我们所有人都在经历这一切，因为我们只希望在危机时期做到最好，而且你知道，
And there's not even enough resources for all of them. That's what's already happening right now in Alameda County. The system is just completely overwhelmed. The pressure on the system to do well, and to be good, and to be efficient, and to be clear just feels like a burden. I mean, we're all just experiencing this as we just want to be the best you can be in the time of crisis, and you know,
你还没完全做到，你知道吗？他们不得不继续努力。人们将继续努力让这一切运行得更顺畅。他们会尽力使其尽可能公平。但问题是，无论你在系统上投入多少精力，如果你试图用2000个三明治去喂养8000人。这种数学计算是永远行不通的。像朱莉这样在这个系统中工作、帮助建立这个系统的人，他们知道这一点。他们当然不需要我这个记者来指出这一点。
you're not quite there yet, you know? And they have to just keep working on it. People will keep trying to make this whole thing run more smoothly. They'll try to make it as fair as possible. But the thing is, no matter how much you work on the system, if you're trying to feed 8,000 people with 2,000 sandwiches. That math is just never going to work out. And people like Julie, who work in this system, who helped build it, they know this. They certainly don't need me a reporter to point it out.
他们时刻感受着系统的缺陷，这让他们很难受。直到我与朱莉的采访快结束、我起身准备离开时，我才意识到到底有多难受。嗯，谢谢你。这很棒。我不知道这年头是不是有很多人哭泣，但这确实很难。哦，天哪。这对我来说并不难。我坐在这里，但我只是想到世界上所有那些一线人员。这就像这些天感受到的。我的意思是，街上的每个人，所有做评估的工作人员，你知道，
They feel the system's deficiencies all the time, and it's hard on them. It wasn't until the end of my interview with Julie, as I was getting up to leave, that I realized just how hard. Well, thank you. It's great. I don't know if lots of people cry out there these days, but it is tough. Oh, man. And it's not tough for me. I sit here, but I just think about all those frontline people in the world. It's like feeling it these days. I mean, everyone on the streets, all the workers who are doing the assessment, you know,
就像所有人一样。这年头真的是一段极其残忍的时期。外面的每个人都感受到这种要做得更多的压力。人们正在做很多事情。人们真的在做很多事情。只是还有更多的事情要做。不仅仅是朱莉。我和许多在这个系统中工作的交谈过的人都有这种感觉：他们被要求解决这个问题，却没有获得解决问题所需的资源。就像来自2-1-1的罗莎娜（Roshana）。
like everybody. It's just an incredibly brutal time these days. And everyone out there is feeling this pressure to do more. And people are doing a lot. People are really doing a lot. And there's just a lot more to be done. It's not just Julie. So many of the people I talk to who work in this system have the sense that they are being asked to solve this problem without having been given the resources to do it. Like Roshana from 2-1-1.
她告诉我，她现在对无家可归现象最大的了解是她在工作前所不了解的。那就是对那里的绝大多数人来说，根本没有帮助。他们得到了什么？什么都没有。坐在一个圆圈里给2-1-1打电话并对我们破口大骂，说，你们没有为我做这个和那个。而我们承受了。我们是社区的急诊室。我们承受了。
She told me the main thing she understands now about homelessness, that she didn't understand before the job. Is that for most people out there, there is no help. What are they getting? Nothing. Sit back in a circle to call to one one and cuss us out and say, you guys aren't doing, you know, this and that for me. And we take it. We're the emergency room for the community. We take it.
但这就好像，我们分享我们的挫败感。我们不喜欢告诉人们我们没有这些资源。我在这个系统的不同角落工作的每个人都希望有更多的资源。像阿拉米达县这样的地方社区一直在争先恐后地寻找新的收入来源，因为他们从HUD得到的资金远远不够。投票提案、销售税、州基金。如果我们想帮助现在无家可归的人，我们需要这个系统拥有完成这项工作所需的所有资源。
But it's like, we share our frustrations. Like, we don't like telling people we don't have these resources. Every person I'm at working in the different corners of this system wanted there to be more resources. And local communities like Alameda County are always scrambling to find new revenue sources since they don't get anywhere near enough funding from HUD. Ballot initiative, sales taxes, state funds. And if we wanna help the people who are homeless right now, we will need this system to have all of the resources it requires to do that.
但这并不能真正解决更大的问题，因为这个系统根本不是为做到这一点而设计的。当无家可归现象在20世纪80年代开始爆发时，人们并不明白发生了什么。我们把它归咎于去机构化和快克可卡因。无家可归是那些身体不健康的人身上发生的事情，我们建立了一个系统来应对那些看起来最不健康、最无力解决自己无家可归问题的人，我们称他们为最脆弱的人。
But that won't actually solve the bigger problem because this system just wasn't designed to do that. When homelessness started exploding in the 1980s, people didn't understand what was happening. We blamed it on the institutionalization and crack. Homelessness was something that happened to people who weren't well, and we created a system to respond to the people who seemed the least well, the least capable of solving their own homelessness, the most vulnerable we call them.
但越来越多的专家一致认为，无家可归并不是由精神疾病或成瘾引起的。这些事情可以作为催化剂，但它们不是原因。原因是经济上的。如果人们拿最低工资却负担不起住房，或者靠社会保障或残疾救济金却负担不起住房。你就会无家可归，这就是为什么经历这一切后，我清楚地感觉到，无家可归者服务系统无法解决无家可归问题。我想，如果理解这个系统的旅程就像打开一套
But increasingly experts agree that homelessness isn't caused by mental illness or addiction. Those things can serve as the catalyst, but they aren't the cause. The cause is economic. If people can't afford housing, making minimum wage or can afford housing, if they're on social security or disability. You're just going to have homelessness, which is why it feels clear to me after all of this, that the homeless service system cannot solve homelessness. And I guess if the journey into understanding this system has been like opening a set
俄罗斯套娃，这就是最中心的那一个。这个系统无法解决无家可归问题，它只能应对它。它能治疗症状，但不能治疗疾病。目前，它甚至没有把症状治疗得很好。我们仍在谈论无家可归，就好像它是关于今天街上的人一样。让人难以置信，你知道吗。你可能认出那个声音，那是萨姆斯·巴里切斯。但那是，我们如何把这些无家可归的人赶出街道？我们怎么处理这些无家可归的人？
of Russian nesting dolls, this is the one at the center. This system can't solve homelessness, it can only address it. It can treat the symptoms, but not the disease. And currently, it's not even treating the symptoms all that well. We are still talking about homelessness, like it's about the people on the street today. It's unbelievable to make you know. You may recognize that voice, it's Sam's embarrassed. But that was like, how do we get these homeless people off the street? What do we do with these homeless people?
我的意思是，这些只是一个创造无家可归的速度远远快于我们结束无家可归的速度的系统的当前受害者。所以这就好像，即使你把现在街上的这6-8万人都安置了，你也没有结束无家可归，因为明年你会有2万，后年会有4万和6万。在某种程度上，萨姆斯对最脆弱人群的工作促成了我们现在拥有的系统，该系统只关注他们。但萨姆斯认为，如果我们真的想解决无家可归问题，
I mean, these are just the current victims of a system that's creating homelessness much faster than we are ending it. So it's like even if you took this 60 or 80,000 people that are on the streets right now and house them, you haven't ended homelessness because next year you're going to have 20 in the year after 40 and 60. In some ways it was Sam's work with the most vulnerable that led to the system we have now, which focuses only on them. But Sam thinks that if we're really gonna solve homelessness,
我们将不得不通过确保极低收入人群能够获得他们负担得起的住房，来防止人们最终陷入无家可归。这就是我们在80年代之前所拥有的。萨姆斯想要把它找回来。不是像以前那样把穷人隔离在贫民窟里，而是大规模的混合收入开发。建设8万套经济适用房的计划在哪里？每个人都在谈论，哦，我们每年会建造
we're gonna have to prevent people from ending up homeless in the first place by making sure that extremely low income folks have access to housing they can afford. That's what we had before the 80s. Sam wants that back. Not the way it was then with poor people sequestered in ghettos, but mixed income development on a massive scale. Where's the plan to build 80,000 units of affordable housing? Everyone talks about, oh, we'll do
200套。所以我们刚刚得到了400套。这就好像，那又怎样？我的意思是，也不是真的“那又怎样”，但它就像是，“那又怎样”。萨姆斯在谈到这一切时情绪非常激动。他愤怒的是，作为一个社会，我们没有投资去真正解决这个问题。我们只是做了这些半心半意的措施，然后却纳闷为什么它们不管用。我们没有做真正需要做的事情，而是围绕着为极少数人解决无家可归问题建立了一个完整的系统、一整套产业。
200 units a year. So we just got 400 units. It's like, so what? I mean, not really so what, but it's like, but so what. Sam gets so worked up when he talks about all of this. He's infuriated that as a society, we don't invest in truly fixing this problem. We just do these half measures and then wonder why they haven't worked. Instead of doing what really needs to be done, we've built a whole system, a whole industry around addressing homelessness for a very, very small number of people.
但萨姆斯仍然在这个系统内部工作，当我问他为什么没有彻底放弃它时，他说这是因为它仍然值得。即使只是安置一个人也很重要。在上一集的《根据需求》中，一个人终于从这个系统得到了东西。那么，萨姆斯，你现在的生活中还在发生什么？我的生活中没有别的了，凯蒂。这就是我的世界。我生活并呼吸着，你知道，无家可归。然后我试着去散步，好暂时不去想它。休息之后，即将播出的《根据需求》最终集的预览。
But Sam still works inside this system, and when I ask him why he hasn't just given up on it completely, he says it's because it's still worth it. It still matters to house even just one person. On the last episode of According to Need, one person finally actually get something from this system. Well, what else is going on in your world right now, Sam? Nothing else is going on in my world, Katie. This is my world. I live in breathe, you know, homelessness. And then I try and go to walks to stop thinking about it for a little bit. After the break, a preview of our final episode coming up on according to need.
为什么下雨？去他的帐篷。嘿，嗨。我们不想违法，但我们必须生活在某个地方并为自己睡觉，就像我需要生活一样。现在你不会帮凯西弄水。你想让我做这件事，因为我正在挖沟来保护她的帐篷。我正试图弄清楚你可能会使用紧急逃生口的情况。我不知道。我真的知道他在那儿。
Why is it raining? Screw the tent. Hey, hi. We don't want to break the law, but we have to live somebody's and have to sleep for them just like I need to live. Now you won't help Casey get water. You want me to do it, as I'm digging a ditch to save her tent. I was trying to figure out the situation in which you might use your escape hatch. I don't know. I really know him.
就像知道他在那儿一样。在伯克利找一个带代金券的像样的房子真的很难。如果你在伯克利找到一个带代金券的房子，它们往往不是最好的地方。你知道的，在大学附近，它们租的不是公寓，不是卧室、床位，而是每月1200美元。这太离谱了。她有没有告诉你什么时候可以听到消息？她说，你周二或周三就知道我排在名单的什么位置了，所以。
He's just like knowing it's there. Yeah, like knowing he's there. It's really hard to find a decent place in Berkeley with a voucher. If you do find a place in Berkeley with a voucher, they tend not to be the nicest places. You know, they're renting not apartments, they're not bedrooms, beds, for 1200 a month in the college. That's outrageous. And did she tell you when you could expect to hear anything? She said, you know where I stood on the list by Tuesday or Wednesday, so.
到达名单顶端只是个开始。实际从系统中获得帮助是什么样的。下期《根据需求》为您揭晓。本集的《根据需求》由我凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）制作，副制片人是艾比·麦登（Abby Medon），主编是惠特尼·亨利·莱斯特（Whitney Henry Lester）。非常感谢安娜·利瓦（Anna Liva）、贾米·阿尔曼扎（Jami Almanza）、丹尼斯·库尔海恩（Dennis Cullhain）、艾莉森·D·杨（Allison D. Young）、雷吉娜·坎农（Regina Cannon）、
Getting to the top of the list is just the beginning. What it looks like to actually get help from the system. That's next time on According to Need. This chapter of According to Need was produced by me, Katie Mingle with Associate Producer Abby Medon and Managing Editor Whitney Henry Lester. Huge thanks to Anna Liva, Jami Almanza, Dennis Cullhain, Allison D. Young, Regina Cannon,
杰西·西蒙（Jesse Shimon）、奥申·纽曼（Ocean Newman）和E. N. D.杨，他们都花时间和我谈论了这份名单。罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）是《根据需求》的执行制片人。丽莎·波洛克（Lisa Pollock）、埃姆内特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）和罗曼·马尔斯提供了宝贵的编辑意见。布莱森·巴恩斯（Bryson Barnes）是我们的音响工程师，艾米·盖恩斯（Amy Gaines）负责事实核查，优美的音乐由才华横溢的肖恩·拉尔（Sean Raal）创作，品牌和设计由muchmore.io负责。库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是我们的数字总监，索菲亚·克拉特斯克（Sofia Klatsker）、维维安·李（Vivian Leigh）和克里斯·贝鲁贝（Chris Berrubay）提供了额外支持。特别感谢玛丽·索尔明迪纳-卡雷纳（Marie Solmindina-Karena）、约翰娜·佐恩（Johanna Zorn）和切尔西·米勒（Chelsea Miller）。
Jesse Shimon, Ocean Newman, and E. N. D. Young, who all spent time talking to me about the list. Roman Mars is the Executive Producer of According to Need. Invaluable editing from Lisa Pollock, Emmett Fitzgerald, Delaney Hall, Christopher Johnson, Joe Rosenberg, and Roman Mars. Bryson Barnes was our sound engineer, fact checking by Amy Gaines, beautiful music by the beautiful Sean Raal, branding and design by muchmore.io. Kurt Colstead was our digital director, additional support from Sofia Klatsker, Vivian Leigh, and Chris Berrubay. Special thanks to Marie Solmindina-Karena, Johanna Zorn, and Chelsea Miller.
《根据需求》是99%隐形（99% Invisible）的一个项目，该节目是来自PRX的Radio Topia的自豪创始成员，Radio Topia是一个由独立听众支持、艺术家所有的播客网络。Radio Tapio。这个节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
According to Need is a project of 99% invisible, which is a founding proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a network of independent listener-supported artist-owned podcasts. Radio Tapio. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《按需分配》是 99% Invisible 的一个项目，也是 PRX 旗下 Radio Topia 的自豪创始成员，Radio Topia 是一个由听众资助、艺术家拥有的独立播客网络。Radio Tapio。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。